- So-so-so-solidarité!
- Après deux ans
l'environnement reprennent
le flambeau.
- Les mères au front!
On est là pour nos enfants. du e
de courage politique.
- L'urgence climatique,
tu ne la régleras pas en parlant
d'économie verte. C'est beC'estd
que ça, c'est beaucoup plus
dangereux que ça.
- Le PQ et QS ont présenté
par des experts, mais
pour les manifestants,
ce n'est pas assez.OY,
représentant des syndicatsyndics
- Même ces deux partis-là
ne vont pas assez loin.vendicatt
une sortie complète du pétrole
et du gaz.
- D'ici 2030, et taxer
les plus social. social. social.
VÉRONIQUE LAFLAMME, FRAPRU
- Ce qui est préoccupant
également, c'est le fait
que le parti qui risque de
iquement pas pris
d'engagements à la hauteur
de ce qu'on lui demande.
- Et les manifestants ont tenu
à le dire au ministre sortant
de l'Environnement,
venu participer à la marche.
- Engagez-vous ou dégagez!
- Poursuivi par un certain
nombre d'entre eux,
Benoit Charette a été chassé
avant même que la manifesta mann
ne commence.
Présent sur les lieux,
Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois a réagi.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, co-porte-
parole dolidaire
- La violence, l'intimidation,
les menaces à l'intégrité
physique des personnes,
c'est inacceptable. Scander
des slogans pour dire "on n'est
pas d'accord avec vous", ça,
je pense que ça fait partie
de la liberté d'expression.
- Cette manifestation est
la plus importante depuis celle
Greta Thunberg en septembre 2019
à Montréal. Le mouvement
écologiste avait perdu
de la vigueur avec la pandémie.
La coalition souhaite raviver
la flamme, un appee, un appee, u
par des milliers de personnes
aujourd'hui.
- À nous la rue!
- À qui la rue?
- Ils étaient des centaines
à Sherbrooke, Trois-Rivières,
Rimouski...
À Québec, le troisième lien
pas.
- Moi, je suis très anti-
troisième lien, personnellement
pro tramway!
(cris)
- À O- À O- À O- À O- À Ottawa ,
leur message est directement
envoyés aux élus devant
le parlement.
Bien qu'ils se sentent
dans un dialogue de sourds,
les militants persistent.
Le mouvement Friday for futur
se poursuivra tant que la lutte
ne sera pas gagnée
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau,
Radio-Canada, Mont